Who doesn't love cookies?
This is a recipe that's going
to be very straightforward.
You're going to wow everybody
who has these cookies.
You are going to learn all of
the tricks of making the best
cookie of your life.
Let's get started.
Let's start with the really
basic, which is mise en place.
What that means is gathering
everything in its place
before you start the recipe.
So I start with the chocolate.
With a chef's knife,
I'm just going
to take this chunk of chocolate
and cut down like this.
So I'm going to make sure all
of the chocolate is about half
an inch to an inch in size.
For me, a chocolate
chunk is what
I want when I'm eating
a chocolate chip cookie.
Place your bowl on the scale,
and then you press tare.
And that zeros it out so that
it doesn't take into account
the weight of the bowl.
I'm going to start measuring
till I get about 255.
So I have 255
grams of chocolate.
Can you imagine if I
tried to figure out
how many cups this is?
Like if you chop your
chocolate really small
and then if I chop
it kind of big,
we're going to end up with
two totally different amounts.
I weigh everything.
I'm going to tare again.
So that zeros it out.
Now I can add milk chocolate.
I'm just going to
start shaving it down.
This one's a little bit easier
to cut because it's softer.
I need about 70 grams,
so I've tared the scale.
72, almost perfect.
So now we have our 255
grams of dark chocolate
and about 70 grams
of milk chocolate.
Now I've got my second bowl.
150 grams of granulated sugar.
This is three quarters of a cup.
I'm just going to measure this
out, and we've got our 150.
And then in the
same bowl, I'm going
to measure the Brown sugar.
Tare that.
Now brown sugar
is a great example
of why we want to use a scale
rather than a measuring cup.
It looks like it's taking up
this much room in the bowl.
But you can pack it down.
So that means that if you're
measuring brown sugar using
a cup measurement, if I'm
a cup measurement,
we might end up
with two totally
different measurements
depending on who packs
down the brown sugar more.
So that's why we
measure with the scale.
In the same bowl, 165
grams of brown sugar.
The next thing we're
going to measure out
is our dry ingredients.
I'm going to start out
with a nice big bowl,
and remember to tare so
that you start back at 0.
High gluten bread
flour, 160 grams.
By measuring everything
out with a scale,
it also just makes
things so much easier.
You don't have to have
multiple cup measures.
You can just go ahead
and dump everything
straight into the dry mix.
I actually like
a cookie that has
a little bit of like thickness
and a little bit of chew.
So we've added the
high gluten flour,
going to tare that again.
Now we have your basic all
purpose flour, 150 grams.
So now we've got
the flour measured.
We're going to add a
teaspoon of baking soda.
Now with stuff like
baking soda, we're
using these items,
these ingredients
in such small measures that the
scale doesn't really register.
I go with the teaspoon measure.
So we've got a teaspoon
of baking soda.
We have a half a
teaspoon of kosher salt.
So I have two large eggs.
And these are at
room temperature.
And you're going to crack them
directly into a small bowl.
Then we're going to add a
teaspoon of vanilla extract.
I don't want little pockets
of egg yolk to be in the mix.
So I'm going to
whisk it all together
to try to create
something that's
a little bit homogeneous.
The eggs are at room
temperature because when
we are going to mix the
cookie dough together,
we're going to
spend a lot of time
creaming that butter
and sugar together.
The butter is going
to start to soften.
It's going to get aerated
with all of the sugar.
If the eggs are cold, as soon
as the eggs hit the butter
and sugar, it's going to
cause the butter to firm up.
We're going to cream the heck
out of it, make it really light
and fluffy.
Let's put together this dough.
We're going to start
with unsalted butter.
The ideal temperature when
creaming butter and sugar
when you have a stick like
this is that you can bend it.
First, mixing up the butter
and then adding the sugar.
If you buy salted butter
in the grocery store,
there are different brands.
And you really don't
know how much salt
has been added to the butter.
Creaming butter and
sugar, that is not a step
that you want to skip.
It adds such a huge difference
to the texture of the cookie
so that you get that really
nice light chewy texture.
If it gets to the point where
the butter is so warm that it
starts to melt, all of those
air pockets start to collapse.
After you've put the
butter in the mixing bowl
is to then add the sugar.
We've got both the
mix of the brown sugar
and the white sugar.
We're going to go
ahead and get started.
Let's start this
at a slow speed.
It should take about 3
to 5, maybe 8 minutes
to get this beautiful fluffy
butter and sugar mixture.
Basically, the term creaming
butter and sugar together
is when you mix butter and
sugar together and keep
mixing it, and mixing
it, and mixing it
until it lightens in color.
In fact, it turns
to almost the color
of like heavy cream, which is
how it gets its name, creaming
butter and sugar together.
Now why is that so important?
If you were to have a
microscope here and take
either the brown sugar
or the white sugar
and look at it
under a microscope,
you know that
sugar is a crystal.
Now these hard
crystals when they
go into your softened butter are
basically aerating your butter.
I'm going to take a spatula
and really get into the bowl.
A lot of times, the
butter will collect.
Make sure that it gets loosened
so that it can all get creamed
together with your sugar.
Imagine all of those
sugar crystals creating
all of the air in
the butter, and just
let your mind
relax a little bit.
Just in case there's
any last bits
that I didn't get
the first time,
I usually do this about twice.
Now these eggs are again
at room temperature.
So I'm going to turn the
mixer on kind of a low speed.
Slowly drizzle it in so that
it has time to fully mix in
to the butter and sugar.
Great.
Now the egg, and the butter,
and the sugar are all mixed in.
So it's not going to be
quite as fluffy because we've
added a little bit of egg.
But it should be kind
of creamy looking.
And you don't want pieces of egg
mixed in with pieces of butter.
You really want it to
be kind of homogeneous
because if it's separated, then
when the dry ingredients hit
it, then the dry ingredients are
going to latch on to the egg,
and they're going to
latch on to the butter,
and you're going to end up
with weird little pockets.
Let me give it another scrape.
Make sure we get all of that.
And this is looking
really beautiful.
Now I did want to
show you-- you can
see like when I
cracked the egg, there
was a little bit of egg shell.
So this is why we
crack into the bowl
and then pour the eggs
because if this ends up
in somebody's
cookie-- have you ever
had a cookie with egg shell?
It's like-- you'd think
it wouldn't be so bad.
You think it'd be nice and
crunchy, but it's pretty nasty.
Great.
Let's now mix our chocolate
in with the flour.
So the reason I mix the
chocolate into the flour
is that that way I can combine
the flour into the egg, sugar,
and butter mixture with
minimal gluten development
because, remember,
the gluten will
start developing as soon as
the flour hits anything liquid.
I like to mix this
part with the mixer.
And then I like to finish
it by hand because I
don't want to over mix.
If I were to turn this on, all
the flour would go everywhere.
So I'm just going to
pulse on/off, on/off.
So I've mixed it pretty
much all the way.
But I'm actually going to
finish mixing it by hand.
I like to finally
feel the dough.
I've let the machine
do everything.
And now I want to do something.
So let's go ahead
and take this out.
And then also it allows me to
control how much mixing we're
doing so that we don't
overwork the dough.
Butter and sugar both
inhibit gluten development.
So I'm not too worried about
getting a cookie dough that's
going to be tough.
But as I'm mixing, I make
sure it's all been mixed in,
and now it's ready to go.
Now this chocolate
chip cookie dough,
you don't want to
bake it right now.
These will be a
thousand times better
if you let the dough rest
overnight in the fridge.
That flour is going to absorb
more of the liquid that's
in the eggs and in the butter.
And it's going to bake off
into a much better cookie.
So take your dough, and scrape
it into an airtight container.
Take the time to rest the dough.
What that does is it
hydrates the flour
so that you end up with a really
beautiful, thick chocolate chip
cookie.
And now we're going to scoop
and bake these cookies.
We're going to go ahead and put
about six cookies per trade.
I like to place them
2 to 3 inches apart.
They're going to
spread a little bit.
So you do want to give
them a little bit of room.
Ideally, you're going to want to
bake one cookie tray at a time
because, that way,
you'll have even airflow
above and below
the cookie sheet.
Your cookies will bake
off nice and evenly.
But let's be real.
You've got two cookie sheets.
Are you really going
to want to wait?
So I won't be upset if
you bake two at a time.
Just know that if
you really want
to do this perfectly right,
you should bake one at a time.
Now that I've got
my cookie scooped,
we're going to go ahead
and go to the oven
and start baking our cookies.
Make sure you have
an oven thermometer
so that you know that the
oven is actually at 350.
So let's go ahead
and go to the oven.
At the end of the day,
you are in your kitchen,
looking at your product,
working with your oven.
And so I really want
you to learn how
to bake by sight and by touch.
Even though you might have an
oven thermometer that says 350,
my oven thermometer
says 350, there's
so much variation in ovens.
The oven isn't just
staying at a static 350.
What happens is the
oven is triggered.
Once it goes below a certain
point, the heat kicks in again.
And then it brings it
up a certain point.
And so ovens kind of waver
between 10 degrees, 5 degrees.
It depends on your oven.
So I just pulled these
amazing chocolate chip cookies
out of the oven, and I'm
going to let them rest here
for about 10 minutes
before I take them off
and put them on
the cooling tray.
I think we should try
some of the warm cookies.
Oh my gosh.
Is your cookie like this?
There's like gooey
milk chocolate
and gooey dark chocolate inside.
And so let's go ahead and--
mm.
What am I looking for?
You can see visually your
cookies are golden brown.
It's pale in the center.
But they're totally cooked
through in the center.
If you pull them out
too early, you're
going to end up with this
little pocket of raw dough.
It won't be the
end of the world.
But, ideally, you
want the cookie
to be baked all the way through.
For me, the perfect
chocolate chip cookie
is kind of balanced with
a lot of chocolate flavor.
It's got a crispy edge.
It's got a tender melt
in your mouth center.
It's got big pieces of
chocolate all throughout.
There's also a little
hint of molasses.
It's from the brown sugar
and a little caramel
from the milk chocolate.
And then there's just
a little bit of salt.
We put in that kosher
salt into the recipe.
And you can actually taste
a little hint of salt.
It's not salty by any means.
But it's enough salt
to really draw out
the flavors of the butter,
the vanilla, and all
of the chocolate.
They are definitely best eaten
day of that you bake them.
But if you store
them, they should
last about two more days
in an airtight container.
So now you've become
a star cookie baker.
If you really want to
improve your cookie baking,
there's one simple trick.
Just keep making cookies.
And who's going to
complain about that?
Making cookies over
and over again,
you will get so much
practice, and you
will learn how every single
little adjustment you make
changes the result
of the cookie.
And you'll be able to
fine-tune your own technique so
that you can be the
best cookie baker ever.
[MUSIC PLAYING]